The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu
RUSS TEDRAKE: Today
we're going to do
sort of the second part of
our discussion on walking.
I want to start with what
sounds like a little bit
of a remedial
question in some ways,
in numerical analysis
of these walking kids.
Because it forces us to be
more careful about talking
about the dynamics through
collisions and on Poincare
maps.
OK.
So I actually want to
start the discussion
by just asking given
we've defined a walking
robot with some stance dynamics,
and some sort of collision
dynamics, like we did
for the rimless wheel
and the compass gait and the
neat compass gait, quickly.
I just want to ask
the simple question.
Can you find the stable
limits cycles or even
any periodic gaits
of the system?
OK.
So the first question, I
want to find equilibrium,
fixed points of
the Poincare map.
OK.
So remember we talked
about Poincare analysis
of limited cycle
behaviors last time.
And we said that this continuous
time, stable oscillation
could be nicely characterized
as a discrete time, fixed point
analysis.
If we're able to, for
instance, for the van der Pol
oscillator--
and call that x the next dot
on the van der Pol oscillator.
If we're able to design
some surface of section,
and just look at the state
of the system every time
it goes through that
surface of section,
then I can build a Poincare map.
On the Poincare,
I've got a state x,
which is just some potentially
nonlinear mapping from the nth
crossing of this map to
the n plus 1 crossing
of the mapping of the
surface of section.
So given I have some sort
of bisecting surface here,
what I'd like to do is
now find the fixed points
of that solution, which means
xp star is just p of x p star.
Simple enough.
And that should tell me
where I've got a fixed point,
and, therefore, where
I have a limit cycle.
It doesn't actually
imply necessarily
that limit cycle is stable.
If it was stable,
then you could imagine
finding the fixed
point, for instance,
of the van der Pol oscillator
just by simulating the van der
Pol oscillator for enough time.
I'll eventually go and
do the work for you
and find its way to
the stable fixed point
if you just run
along long enough.
But if it's unstable,
that's not as easy to do.
And for systems like
the compass gait,
it turns out the
basin of attraction
is sort of small enough that you
could spend a long time trying
to find initial
conditions, which
happened to simulate their way
into the stable fixed point.
OK.
So you want to do better
and get some better tools.
Given what we've talked about
in other parts of the class,
if you want to define
the roots of this--
the fixed points of the
system, how would you do it?
I just slipped a little bit and
gave you half the answer there.
How would you do it?
I've got some big,
complicated function p.
I want to find the fixed points.
Close.
So I want to find the roots
of some function of xp.
So it's equivalent to
finding the roots--
the roots of pxp
star minus xp star.
So if I can evaluate p through
simulation or whatever,
then I can evaluate this.
And I could just hand it
to MATLAB or something
and say, find me the roots
of this nonlinear function.
OK.
And that's easy enough.
We talked about
the Newton method
for finding roots
quickly, and we
talked about the constraint
solvers that SNOPT and the like
uses.
OK.
So in fact, we could just
hand this to SNOPT as is,
and ask it to do its thing.
And it would do
numerical derivatives
and would find its way to
some zero of that function.
We're going to be a lot
better shape, though,
if we can compute the
gradients of that analytically.
And hand it to SNOPT.
It would take a
lot fewer trials.
And I want to sort of do
that exercise quickly,
computing the gradients
of the Poincare map.
Because it's going to be
broadly useful in control.
And because it forces us
to really think about how
we define that Poincare map.
OK.
So what we'd like
to do, we just say
it's easier if we have
partial p partial x
available for the optimization.
OK.
Just think ahead
for a second here.
How would you compute if I would
just ask you on the street,
I've got a Poincare map, how
would I compute the gradients.
What would you think?
What would you
start trying to do?
Yeah.
So where we analyze the
perturbations before?
What kind of tools
go with that idea?
Yeah.
So again around any given point
which defines the trajectory,
we could do backprop
through time
if we cared about
a cost function.
But remember the
trick behind backprop
through time, computing
those gradients,
the reason that was
so efficient was
because we were trying to
find the gradient with respect
to a scalar output.
So backprop through
time did a forward pass,
and then connected it to that
scalar cost function output.
And then backed up a
minimal state vector.
The forward version
we talked about
was just computing the
gradients marching forward.
And I called that real time
recurrent learning, RTRL.
And that's actually sort
of 80% of what you need
to compute the gradient here.
Is there something I did wrong?
No.
OK.
So RTRL, which we've
talked about before
and I'll say again real quickly
here, is a lot of the answer.
But there's a subtlety
that I want you to see.
OK.
So let's be a little careful
about how we go from xp of m
over to xp n plus 1.
That mapping is sort
of a complicated--
there's a transition from
this discrete time system
to the continuous time
dynamics, a simulation
of those continuous
time dynamics.
Potentially, an
impact map at the end.
We talked about
the rimless wheel
doing the Poincare map
right at the impact.
So let's do that carefully.
So let me define xp at m
as being equivalent to,
in continuous time, x,
the original vector--
I used a p to denote the
discrete time, Poincare thing--
at the time of collision
of the nth collision.
In the walking case, we
always did our Poincare map
at the same time
as the collision.
And more generally,
you could just
think of this as
sort of a collision
with a surface of section.
OK.
In the walking case, because
the collision has some dynamics,
we want to be explicit
about whether it's
before or after those dynamics,
before or after the collision.
So I'm going to call
our discrete time
state of our system to be
the state of the system
immediately after I process
that collision dynamics.
So I'm going to
put a plus there.
Minus would be just
before the collision.
Yeah.
They're both at the
same time, but there's
an instantaneous dynamics.
OK.
So I have this.
I know how to go from xp
to a continuous time thing.
And then I know how to go from
this to march that forward.
If I know when the
next collision is,
then I know that
had better just be
x of tc plus n plus the
integral from tc plus n
to tc minus n plus 1.
Let's just say my dynamics
are x dot equals f of x.
I forget about control for a
second just to keep it simpler.
Once I go from my
discrete time thing
to a continuous
time thing, I just
integrate my equations
of motion forward
until I collide with the
surface of section again.
And I want tc defined somehow.
I want to somehow define
that surface of section.
And to define that surface
of section and that collision
time, I'm going to define--
or more generally a collision--
as some function
that equals zero.
There's some manifold
of states that I
can describe by this
function, which will
define my surface of section.
So what was it for the
van der Pol oscillator?
I designed my surface of section
to be this thing going forward.
So what the surface
of section is
defined as some function which
just happens to be zero here.
So a perfectly good candidate
would be like the distance,
the signed distance let's say,
between your current state
and that manifold.
You OK with that?
I don't think I
said that very well.
But if I want to know--
define my surface of
section, just define
a function of state, which
is non-zero everywhere
and zero where the
surface I care about is.
Yeah.
And that's going to
allow me, as you'll see,
to do things like taking
the gradient of knowing
when I'm going to collide
with that surface of section.
So this could just
be for instance
the signed distance
between, let's say,
the foot of the
robot and the ground.
Yeah.
So when the robot's
foot hits the ground,
that thing's going to be zero.
When it's below
the ground, it'll
be some negative distance.
When it's above
the ground, it'll
be some positive distance.
OK now that's going to allow
me then to define this.
At a time of
collision, this thing
is going to add better be zero.
Good so I would I'd
want to define it
in a way that
doesn't include that.
So I could put a--
so the robot's foot
colliding with the ground
doesn't have that problem,
if you think about it.
But I do typically put something
like a velocity term in it.
Let me just write
down what I would
use for the rimless wheel.
Actually, I've got it here.
So I do phi of x is just sine,
the sine function of theta
dot times theta minus
gamma minus alpha.
So if you don't remember
all those symbols,
that's almost useless.
But this is saying--
the sine of theta dot tells me
if the robot's moving forward,
then I'm going to
look for the collision
with the ground at this angle.
And if the robot's
looking backwards,
I'm going to actually
look at the collision
with the ground at that angle.
And that's how I end up getting
the surface of section which
doesn't go--
just goes in the top half
and bottom half of the thing.
So you can divide
whatever function,
but you just want
it to be not 0 here.
OK we're getting closer to
having this be well defined.
In fact, this is
a very common way
to define a collision
in any hybrid system.
So systems that are continuous
with discrete impacts
are called hybrid systems.
If you wanted to simulate
a hybrid system in MATLAB
with ODE, then you
would very much
do that by defining
a function, which
they call a collision function
or a collision event function,
which has got 0's here.
And you can hand,
as your options
to the ODE solvers in MATLAB,
event functions like this.
And they will very carefully
watch a crossing of that event
function across 0, and pinpoint
the time and state at which
that thing goes across 0.
So this is a very common
notation in hybrid systems
kind of worlds.
It turns out if we
do care about finding
this gradient of
the Poincare map,
then this is going to be also be
the enabling thing which allows
us to compute that gradient.
OK So we have this x of t minus.
We've gone from just
after a collision.
We've integrated forward
over a continuous dynamics.
Yeah.
So now we're at the time
of the new collision, tc
minus n plus 1.
We're going to compute
the new dynamics by having
some collision function.
In the rimless
wheel, it was just
the thing that took
out some energy because
of the inelastic
collision with the ground.
So the final piece of the
puzzle here is x of p n
plus 1, which is equivalent
to x of tc plus n plus 1,
which is some impact dynamics.
I'll just call it big f
of x of tc minus n plus 1.
In 90% of cases that
I would care about,
it's only a function of x.
I like to write in the
more general form in case
you have things like
moving obstacles.
Let's say.
In the surface of section
case for limit cycles,
I think it'd be
pretty unusual to have
a direct dependence on time.
But it doesn't make an our
derivation any more complicated
than if you had--
you wanted to worry
about collisions
with moving things or something
like that, you could do that.
OK.
So this is a sufficient recipe
now for simulating the Poincare
map.
If I want to just
evaluate in the simulation
with the Poincare
map, someone says
I'm at state xp on
the nth Poincare map,
I'm going to turn that into
my continuous time thing.
I'm going to integrate
forward my dynamics,
just like we always do.
But I'm going to stop at a
particular time, tc minus,
which is defined as the
time when it causes phi
to equals zero.
And then at that time, in
the case of the walking
robots or any collisions,
physical collisions,
you might have to implement the
discrete collision dynamics.
And that takes you
back to the next map.
Good.
So how do we take the
gradients of that?
It's almost trivial,
almost trivial.
We know how to take the
gradients off of this.
We'll do it again,
just in one line.
But we know how to
just integrate forward
the gradient dynamics to compute
the long term gradients of x.
The only subtlety is that--
so when I'm computing
the gradient,
I'm changing xp a little bit.
I'm trying to do a sensitivity
analysis between x.
If I change xp a
little bit, how is it
going to change xp n plus 1?
So the only subtlety is that
when I change xp a little bit,
it can change my collision time.
So you have to
make darn sure when
you're taking the
gradients, that you
capture the changes
in collision time
that are due to your change
in the initial conditions.
Other than that it's almost
exactly the RTRL code
that we've done before.
And that turns out to be not
so bad, so I want to do it.
All right.
So we can just go forward with
the chain rule here, so dxp
of n plus 1 dxp of n.
Well that's going to be,
first of all, the gradient
of this f, partial capital
f partial x and then times
the gradient of the inside.
The inside is defined
by x at a certain time.
So this is where that comes in.
OK.
So first of all,
let me say we're
doing we're doing
this linearization
around some nominal trajectory.
We have some xp0 that
we're linearizing around.
That implies we have
an xt trajectory
that we're linearizing,
around which I'm calling x0.
And it implies that there's
some nominal time of impact--
time of collision that
we're linearizing around,
which I'm calling tc0.
OK.
So the obvious gradient
here, partial f partial x,
gets us past--
gets up backwards with respect
to the impact dynamics.
And then we have to figure
out what the state of x
is relative to the
initial conditions,
at time evaluated at the
original impact time.
And then the subtlety is that I
can also increment or decrement
the index of the integral, the
limits of the integral, which
has the effect of adding
this term again modified
by that increment in the
limit of the integral.
So I get f of x
times that increment.
OK.
So let's do this in a picture.
So let's say I have some thing,
some manifold defined by phi
equals 0.
And I have some
nominal trajectory
that I took to get there.
I got to my switching surface.
I'm calling this x0 of t.
And this one here
is x0 of tc0 plus n,
to be entirely confusing.
It just takes a lot to write.
I could write that
equally well as xp0 of m.
And what I'm trying
to figure out
is what's the state
going to be if I'm
going to simulate my
system from slightly
different initial conditions
when it hits the map.
So using my multi-colored
approach here,
if I take some increment in x0
and I simulate my new dynamics
forward, then maybe I get
something pretty similar.
But at time-- what my
original end of time,
if I evaluated this integral
for the same amount of time,
there's no reason to
expect I would get back
to that switching surface.
So this is my
modified thing at tc0.
But what I would
figure out is where
it's going to be the next
time it hits to the surface.
So you can do that by figuring
out what this difference is.
This is partial x of t given the
initial conditions at time tc0.
That's this term here,
corresponds to this.
Yeah.
But I'd better also add in the
dynamics of this thing pushed
forward by the amount of
time necessary to get me back
to the surface for
that collision.
Yeah.
STUDENT: So you never take the
derivative of the p function?
RUSS TEDRAKE: You do.
I'll show you.
So in order to get
this, we're going
have to take a derivative
of the p function.
I can't tell if people are bored
by this, or intrigued by this,
or don't care.
OK.
Does that makes sense?
Good.
All right.
So how do we figure
out the change--
the increment in time, given
the initial conditions?
Well it's defined based
on that phi equaling 0
is the thing that defines
this collision surface.
So it's going to be
used in computing
that increment in time.
OK.
So if phi equals 0, then
it better also be the case
that dphi dxp of n--
and let me just write this--
tc minus tc n plus 1,
x of tc minus n plus 1.
This is just the
derivative of that thing
based on the changes of in xp.
I've defined that.
I'm saying that even
though I changed xp,
phi had better still be 0.
I'm integrating until
I hit that surface.
So this thing a better equal 0.
And I can take that
derivative with partial phi
tx, partial x--
t evaluated those same places.
OK.
I'll save myself from
writing that last equation,
but obviously I can now
solve this for dtc dxp.
Yeah.
Stepping back just a second,
I'm making an increment here.
I'm defining that, even
though I made that increment,
I still better get
to phi equals 0.
I can look at the change in phi
that could potentially occur.
It's going to also depend on
the change in x and the change
in final time.
And that allows me to solve
for the final time that
must have made that happen.
That must have made it so I get
back to the switching surface.
Yeah.
OK.
That's really the
only thing you need
to know to make
all of your tools
we've used for loop
optimal control,
for instance, for the acrobat
and the cart-pole work
for the walking systems.
The additional advantage
of thinking about this
now as on the Poincare
map is in some ways we
could do even easier control.
OK.
So what did I just solve for?
I solved for
partial p partial x.
Absolutely.
Please.
Yeah.
Good I want questions.
No, not necessarily.
I mean this to say,
so it happens--
it happens that oftentimes
at the surface of section
we want to compute a discrete
collision dynamics, which
is just some other function
which I'm calling capital f.
I don't mean that to be
directly related to that.
I can see that coming right
after the integral that's
confusing.
Want to I call that
something different?
We can call it
something different.
Yeah.
This is the equation--
well in the rimless
wheel example,
it actually says I'm going
to change coordinate systems
back to where my new
leg is on the ground.
So I'm actually going to do
a discrete change in theta,
and I'm going to take away
some of the theta dot.
Because I've lost some energy
into the ground And in general,
when you have collisions
in mechanical systems,
if you model them
as impulses, you're
going to have some
function like f.
All right.
This is equivalent, right, to
being the partial p partial x,
Everybody sees that?
OK.
Not a little bit
of change of phi.
What we're changing, the
thing we're changing, is xp.
STUDENT: And x0 and all
the nots are basically
the initial trajectory we would
have taken without changing.
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes, because
we're doing everything
as an increment.
We're doing an
incremental analysis.
So I want to say that
the new tc is going
to be tc0 plus this increment.
I've defined the
problem that way, again.
So even if I make a
small change in xp,
I still want it to be that
a minute collision point--
I'm not going to call
it a collision point
until phi equals 0.
And if phi's going to
equal 0 along everything,
then it certainly equals
0 on an increment in xp.
Yeah.
So it's tempting to say--
so we've got gradient based
calculations flying around
here.
We've been doing
a lot with that.
I think they're pretty powerful.
It's tempting to say that
if I have a discontinuity,
then it breaks all my
gradient calculations
it doesn't break
them, you just have
to be more careful about them.
Yeah.
OK.
So we can take a gradient
through the impact of a walking
robot.
No problem.
You just have to use this.
OK.
This will be the same if
you're doing a ping pong
robot or something like that.
Anything with collisions,
a mobile robot
that runs into a museum
visitors or something like this,
would also have an impact map.
OK.
So that's all you need to
use all those methods we
did before.
OK.
So if I wanted to now
optimize the trajectory,
let's say, of my
periodic system--
if I had my dynamics
and now we're back.
I did this just in the
simple case of f of x,
but if I had f of x, u and I
wanted to optimize u in order
to do something good on
the Poincare map that
minimizes the cost function,
I can take the gradients.
I can do my optimization.
But this idea of actually
changing to a discrete time
system is a bit empowering too.
You can always do it.
It's not that you only
do it for walking robots.
Any continuous time
system, instead
of looking at it at every
t, I could look at it
at discrete intervals of time.
I could take a ball that
I throw across the room,
has no impact whatsoever
well at the beginning,
and then I could look at
the system at x of time 0,
then x at t equals 1 second,
x of t equals 2 second.
And I could build a
discrete time system
for any of these
continuous time systems.
It's particularly nice to do
it on these walking robots,
because, well, let's do it.
So what have I just done?
I've computed partial p
partial x, which is telling me
that I'm going to have--
I'm approximating, it's
a Taylor expansion,
of my dynamics around
some nominal point.
If x nominal is a fixed
point, or if I just change
my coordinate systems to x
bar is xn minus x nominal n .
And I could do the time
varying thing if I want,
or I could just do it simply
if xbar0 is a fixed point,
then I'm left with
about a model like this.
Careful here.
p's everywhere.
p n plus 1 is a xbar p of n.
OK.
I can immediately look for
the stability of that model
by taking the
eigenvectors, eigenvalues.
Stability conditions
are discrete time
so those eigenvalues had better
be bounded by 1 and negative 1.
It's not the same condition
but perfectly easy
to analyze the stability
of the fixed points.
So now for the--
if I just cared about
analyzing the passive walker,
I've got ways now by
computing partial p partial x,
handing it to SNOPT or something
to solve to find the roots.
I can find the fixed
points and it also
happens that by computing
partial p partial x
I can evaluate the stability
of those fixed points.
Yeah.
The rimless wheels fixed
points, if you remember,
there was two of them.
One was a rolling fixed point.
One was a standing
still fixed point.
Both of them locally stable.
The compass gait, if you
remember the compass gait,
It also can have
multiple fixed points.
It has one fixed point
for a nominal slope.
It has one fixed
point that's walking,
and it actually has an
unstable fixed point.
Now the cool thing is--
so Ambarish Goswami,
who's a friend and does a lot
of the initial confiscated
analysis.
If you start inclining the
ramp steeper and steeper,
then those fixed points change
as a function of the dynamics.
Something really
interesting happens.
It's not surprising that these
are complicated dynamics.
But you actually at some
point, at some critical angle,
you get a period
doubling bifurcation.
So you get an extra
point that corresponds
not to a one step fixed point,
but to a two step fixed point.
So what does that mean?
What does that
correspond to physically?
What is a two step?
What do I mean by two
step on the Poincare map?
So at x of n plus 2 is
going to equal x of n.
But x of n plus 1
doesn't necessarily.
But every other thing
is going to be the same.
So what does that physically
correspond to in the walking?
It's more of a limp I'd say.
Yeah it's some asymmetric gait.
It's like this.
These robots are doing
potentially asymmetric thing.
Every other footstep ends
up landing in the same place
but not every footstep.
OK.
So it's actually-- there's a
lot of interesting work just
looking at these passive
models and just looking
at the stability of
these passive gaits.
OK.
I do want to say
make one note here,
If you're looking at
the eigenvalues of A,
the way I've defined it.
So the trivial condition here
is that the eigenvalues of A
had better be less than--
the magnitude had
better be less than 1.
There's different notations for
working on the Poincare maps.
My notation is to
denote x of p where
x is the same size as
the original vector.
Because that's more useful in
simulation that's more useful
most of our computations.
But remember the
Poincare map effectively
reduces dimensionality
by 1 And in the way
I've written it
here, if you just
look at A that comes out of a
stable periodic oscillation,
there's actually,
the way I've done it,
there's always a
trivial eigenvalue
of 1, which doesn't degrade
the stability of the system.
What does that
eigenvalue correspond to?
If I take my stable
rimless wheel,
I compute A. I take
the eigenvalues.
I see that the system stable.
It goes to my nominal thing.
This is the standard
stability criteria
for discrete time system.
But I notice that there's
actually always a trivial--
there's one eigenvalue
that equals 1.
Good.
People see that?
There's one direction
that I can push it
in which it does not
reject that disturbance,
and that's the
direction-- if you push it
along the limit cycle.
So there's two ways to do it.
I'm sorry to make
it complicated,
but there's two ways to do it.
If I were to have redefined my
coordinate system on the map,
I wouldn't want to call it
x anymore, but something
that reduce the dimensionality
of the map by 1.
And then I could use
this condition alone.
But in the way I've done it
in the notes and in life,
I like to keep this sort of
as the same dimension of x.
And then because I want
limit cycle stability,
it's absolutely the case
that one of the eigenvalue--
there is a direction in which
those disturbances are not
rejected.
That's what I want.
Yeah.
OK.
So the way I describe
it in the notes
is that what you want for
stability of the periodic gait
is you want to ignore the
first eigenvalue of one.
The rest of them better be--
I want it to be only
one direction that
doesn't reject disturbances.
You with me?
OK.
Then there's some
other direction
that doesn't reject
disturbances and then
I start questioning
whether it's stable.
I wouldn't call it stable in
the sense of a limit cycle
stability.
If I could push in some other
direction in state space
and doesn't get
rejected, then it's
not going to return
to that orbit.
There's a special direction
along the orbit, which
I'm allowed to push,
and that's what
defines limits of stability.
But there's only one direction.
Even in high dimensional
space, a 50 dimensional robot
going around, there's
only one place
that trajectory is going
forward that I'm allowed to push
and not reject the disturbance.
Every other one better converge
for me to call it stable.
OK.
We did the case for the
non-controlled system.
But we're only a
stone's throw away
from doing the actuated version.
I'm not going to write it
out again, but let's say--
let me do it a
little carefully just
to say what I mean carefully.
So if I want to do
the controlled case,
get back to a system like this.
We talked about in
the policy gradient--
in the policy research world--
that I could then define u to
be a tape of u's, or come out
of a linear feedback
control or whatever
sort of parameterization.
But I like to think of it
as being some function which
depends on a parameter vector,
alpha, and can generally
depend on x and u.
So there's a
different way to think
about control in the
discrete time Poincare sense.
One way to think
about it is, let's
say every time I hit
a surface of section,
or my foot hits the ground
in the walking case,
why don't I change the
parameter vector alpha OK.
But I'm going to make
decisions only once per step.
And then I'm going to
execute this policy
for the duration of that cycle.
And then the next
time my foot hits
the ground I'll make a
different decision about alpha.
You can imagine.
So let's say that pi of alpha
and my compass gait walker,
we'll use this example in
simulation in a second.
Let's say I have
a controller that
runs during the
limit cycle which
tries to set my interleg angle
to be some desired value.
Every step I take the
only decision I make
is what should that
desired interleg angle
be for my compass gait.
But over the course
of the cycle,
I'll simulate a
PD controller that
tries to make that
interleg angle happen.
But my discrete time
decisions are just
what interleg angle should I be.
Fumi has got a compass gait
that works with open loop
trajectories that play out,
where his major parameters
are the frequency and phase
of the periodic input.
It's amazingly
stable coming out.
It's like a beautiful example
of open loop stability.
OK.
So Fumi and I have been
talking about changing
the parameters of his open
loop controller once per step,
in order to try to regulate
the behavior of the system.
OK.
There's lots of ways
you could do it.
But, generally, what
that gives you--
if you just try to compute these
exact same gradients again,
we've computed the gradient with
respect to the initial state.
But we could also compute a
gradient with respect to alpha.
And what that could give me
here is a model like this.
I call it B because I'm
thinking of alpha like a control
decision.
Where alpha bar of n is the
difference between my control
decision at n minus whatever
the nominal alpha is.
OK.
So let's say I find a stable
limit cycle where I just
command the interleg
angle to be, I don't know,
pi/4 every step.
And I can find a stable
limit cycle behavior.
Well if someone pushes my
robot, computing these A and B
matrices give me
a nice, simple way
to make discrete decisions to
try to stabilize that robot.
If I'm away from
my limit cycle, I
can correct for those
differences by just saying, OK,
next time take a bigger step
and then take a smaller step.
And how would I design
that rule to change alpha?
How would you design it if
you wanted to make a feedback
law an alpha here?
This is a discrete
time linear system.
I could just hand it to MATLAB
and call LQR, discrete time
LQR.
Give it A, B, Q, and R. It'll
give me back a negative k
alpha, a kx to find alpha.
Are you with me on that?
So the discrete
time summarization
of the dynamics in
this way can actually
make it very natural and very
simple to compute controllers,
which stabilize a walking
cycle for instance, where you
make decisions once per step.
I want to show you some work
that Katie Byl did in my lab,
where she did it on
the nonlinear case
for the compass gait.
Instead of linearizing
this, she went right
with the full
nonlinear Poincare map.
She just did x of n plus
1 is some Poincare map
of x of n parameterized
by alpha, or alpha n.
And the compass gait,
how many dimensions?
What it is it's four
basic dimensions.
There's two angles
and two velocities.
And it's just about
the right size
that you can try discretizing
and doing value iteration.
So Katie had some
nice work showing
that on the compass
gait we can really
get a pretty good sense of
the nonlinear optimal solution
by just popping this
discrete time control
problem into a value
iteration, doing some work,
and computing back an optical
feedback policy, which
tells you where you should
step every time in order
to stabilize your gait.
One better, if you add one more
dimension to your compass gait
robot, you can actually think
about where it is on terrain,
and make it walk
over rough terrain.
So maybe I didn't
spend enough time
in these two lectures
convincing you
that nobody knows how to make
robots walk on rough terrain,
but--
oh shoot, it's going
to take a second here.
But you might know
for yourself that you
don't see a lot of walking
robots walking on rough terrain
yet.
Big Dog's sort of the exception.
Big Dog seems to be pretty good.
We've got a little dog
upstairs in our lab, which
is also pretty good I think.
They're different.
Little dog got can
see the terrain
and Big Dog can't,
so we're supposed
to be doing the long term
research for Big Dog's idea.
Now we've had that
entry music here.
It's a very dramatic
simulation that follows.
OK.
Here's Katie's work on compass
gaits on rough terrain.
A little compass gait robot.
Its making control
decisions every footstep.
It knows where the terrain is.
Pop it into to a big
value iteration solver.
And this thing can walk
over almost anything,
It applies to talk
at the hip width
the PD controller I
described, and it also
puts in an impulse at the foot,
one time every post impact.
So it can push itself
forward a little bit.
So this thing it's pretty good.
And it's just
converting this sort
of complicated looking problem
into a valuation problem.
It doesn't think about
the slope of the terrain.
It could.
But the reason it's
tractable, actually,
if you can tell by the
footprints, it wraps around.
So we've got a limited
state space in x.
We ignore it.
If you look real
carefully, I think
the leg gets a little
shorter every time it goes.
But the mass looks like
there's no dynamics like that.
We built the robot the same
way to have a little tweak
toe that pulls up.
It's trivial in simulation.
Yeah.
How do we do it in real life?
Not as well as we'd like.
Fumi has got a design
that's got a servo that
pushes as fast as we can.
We've talked about pneumatics,
that would be a little faster.
But we haven't run
that, run them yet.
It's interesting.
So she actually did the
case of just hip, just foot.
They both work.
They both stabilize the
walking on moderate terrain.
But together they're much
more stable than the other.
The thing with the hip
one, it always gets
in these configurations like
this and falls backwards.
You need a little bit of
foot energy to get over.
And the one that
pushes off of the toe
keeps putting its foot
down in the wrong place.
There's one thing that Katie's
simulations had problems with.
You guys in my lab know.
But there's a pretty
sort of very visual--
I should find the video maybe.
But there's a very visual
thing that we had problems.
What was the problem
I always talked about
with valuation iteration?
Even if you could
pile the space,
you got to watch
out for something.
Yeah.
Your discretization, if
there's hard discontinuities,
you can do things wrong
in your discretization.
Your discrimination can
be a poor approximation
of your continuous thing.
So Katie stimulated a bunch of
terrain that had holes in it
like cliffs.
And had these
beautiful policies that
would choose their
step across Karate Kid
sort of style terrain.
But every once in
a while, the mesh
points would land
in the wrong place
and the stupid thing
would put its foot
right in the middle of the
hole, right down into the ether.
This is sort of the textbook
case of value iteration
resolution problems.
OK.
So walking isn't any harder
than any other robot really.
There's mechanical challenges.
You have to carry
your actuators.
You're typically dealing with
actuator saturations a lot.
So it's definitely
underactuated.
I don't mean to say it's
easy, because I think
the acrobats are rich and hard.
But it's not
significantly harder
than the acrobat and this is,
remember, the acrobat dynamics.
The only two differences are
that you have to worry about--
you tend to think about Poincare
maps to define stability,
and you have to worry about
these collision dynamics.
You get 100 degree--
I'm not showing you 100 degree
of freedom robot here walking
along but you could.
I mean we're getting there.
So the dork hall type
methods that we're using
with the LTV linearization.
We think that's going to work
pretty nicely for a little dog
and that's 36 dimensional,
walking on very rough terrain.
So there's been a lot
of work in the control
of this, sort of outside
the optimal control
view of the world.
I'd be doing you a disservice
if I didn't tell you
a little bit of it.
Make sure I said
everything I wanted to say.
There was one other
point I wanted to make.
There's something you
can do in discrete time
that you can't really
do in continuous time
when it comes to
stabilizing controllers.
Anybody get it from just that?
I said it very
obtusely, but yeah
Yeah.
Good.
So in discrete
time, I can actually
find an action,
potentially, depends
on B. I could find an
action which would actually
drive me to zero, in my
aerodynamics, in a single step.
In continuous time,
getting there arbitrarily
fast means setting your
gains arbitrarily high.
In discrete time,
that's not the case.
I can set a finite
magnitude gain
that will get me to
zero in a single step.
So that's called
deadbeat control.
It's a very beautiful goal
to have for a walking robot.
if I get perturbed by the
terrain or by someone hitting
me with a baseball
bat or whatever--
you should see the videos
that the robotics people make
of walking robot--
then a very beautiful
goal is to say
that before my next
foot hits the ground,
I'm going to cancel out all
the error for my disturbance.
Certainly you can do that here
if you have no limits on alpha
and if B is full row rank.
Then it's algebraic
equation to compute
what alpha n had better be.
I could just say, if you want
something that could basically
look like feedback
linearization,
I could just cancel that out.
Sometimes you can't
do it, but I want
you to know that's a
beautiful goal for control.
We'll see in the
running bit, we'll
see some running models where
you can do that B control.
The compass gait, if you had
the right parameterization,
you could do compass
gait control.
John and I were debating
this last night.
I don't think that the
PD controller is probably
going to be enough to
give you that B control.
Because it won't simultaneously
take out your energy
and get your foot
in the right place.
But it's possible.
You could actually
do the analysis
and answer that question.
OK.
So thinking about these things
as discrete time control
problems is pretty beautiful.
More generally, though, we can
do control through the swing
phase, in this case.
Or between the
surfaces of section
in a general limited cycle case.
And if you want to
do that, you could do
you could do a shooting method.
You could do deer call.
Optimize some trajectory.
You have to be careful
because the time can change
during your optimization, the
duration of your trajectory,
but you could do that.
And then optimize it.
But just like we showed in the
acrobat and cart-pole case,
people have come up with more--
I don't want to say problem
specific-- but more sort
of problem specific solutions.
So Goswami, Ambarish
Goswami did some nice work.
Can anybody guess?
What's one of the dominant
nonlinear control ideas
we talked about for the
acrobat and cart-pole.
PFL, but that led
to energy shaping.
So Goswami did a nice controller
based on energy shaping.
And he showed that you take
your nominal confiscate
with its fragile little
basin of attraction,
which he computed by sampling.
Pushing the system
until it fell down.
And he showed that with an
energy shaping controller,
which is derived
exactly the same way
we derive the other
one, but I can
regulate the energy of
the system to put me back
on the energetic orbit.
Because this thing
is with zero torque.
It's passive in the swing phase.
So I can just drive
myself up to the place
where I will passively fall
down and hit the right place
on my Poincare map.
And that worked locally.
That's a good idea.
There's another
bunch of work that's
become popular in our world.
Eric Westervelt and Jesse
Grizzelle and these guys
they talk about
hybrid zero dynamics.
And more recently,
our friend who's
going to join the lab,
the advisor in Manchester.
These guys have been doing
sort of similar work using more
optimal control derivations
and similar hybrid
zero dynamic kind of methods.
Let me just cartoon the idea.
It's sort of similar
to the PFL idea.
But these hybrid
zero dynamic methods
are one of the places
where we actually
have proofs of convergence.
And the way they do it, like in
partial feedback linearization,
is that when the system is--
let me say it carefully here.
They find some
desired trajectory
of the robot, which has a
periodic gait that they like.
It has actuated
joints that follow
this trajectory and
passive joints that
follow this trajectory.
If you do a collocated
PFL, if you just
regulate the dynamics
of your system,
you're actuated joints to
follow that trajectory,
then the passive one pretty
much has to do the same,
has to do the right thing.
OK.
So the results that these guys
on the hybrid zero dynamics--
they talk at the zero dynamics
of the resulting output
dynamics you drive
to drive to zero.
Yeah.
When your PFL controller
has done its job--
and has it doesn't
have to be a PFL.
It could be a speed controller.
When you've driven all your
actuated joints to the desired
trajectory, if you parameterized
that trajectory off
let's say the ankle angle,
then your whole big complicated
bipedal robot, five
link ten link whatever.
Looks like a remote wheel
rolling around the stance foot.
And that's a beautiful idea.
So maybe the bigger
idea here is actually.
A lot of the walking
robots you can
think of as having a lot of
actuators at all the joints
and just having
one passive joint.
So a pretty good idea
for a walking robot
is to just drive all of the
actuated joints as a function
of the passive joint.
And that gives you a dynamical
system in one variable.
It's a more complicated
dynamical system
than the rimless wheel.
It's one that you can
design but the analysis
reverts to basically the
rimless wheel type analysis.
OK.
So this hybrid zero dynamics
is roughly that idea.
And then you can sort
of do a rimless wheel.
I have had this debate with
Eric Westervelt many times.
Yeah.
I think it is.
That's a good idea.
Just like PFL is great.
We should use it
for a little while
until we figure out
something better to do.
I think they'd admit that too.
Their stability
guarantees are when
you've driven the
aerodynamics to zero.
You squash the aerodynamics.
And you have to have gains that
are high enough to squash those
arbitrarily fast.
Now the bigger idea
I think is that I
mean you can do sort
of softer feedback,
and get some of the same
type of performance,
but the theory does
depend on squashing.
So all this stuff I
talked about I think
is sort of the right way to
think about walking control.
It's a small fraction
of what people actually
do in the walking robot world.
By far, the dominant approach is
these Honda ASIMO type robots.
Anybody see HRP4C yesterday.
What does it look like?
It looks like a model.
They actually videotaped
a Japanese model
walking in high
heels, and they built
one of their newest that's
the AIST robot by Kawada
Industries.
It's got now sort of a
female Android head on it.
And it works.
I mean, I just saw a few videos.
But it looks pretty good.
The shapes are more
feminine and the gait
was a little bit looser.
But most of the walking
robots out there today,
most of the successful ones,
are all pretty similar to ASIMO.
And ASIMO doesn't do any
of this stuff really.
ASIMO plays one trick.
I can say it is sort
of in a single line.
They try to keep one
foot flat on the ground,
and assume that foot is
bolted to the ground.
And they pretend they're
fully actuated system
and do their
trajectory tracking.
And when they're doing
their trajectory tracking,
they have to make darn sure
that foot doesn't roll off
the ground.
But if you watch
the videos of ASIMO,
you're going to
see it's always got
one foot flat on the ground.
Running is a small excursion.
They just give up on
stability for a little bit,
until they go back
to the place where
they can catch on the ground.
OK.
That's relatively unappealing
compared to these I think,
because it uses a ton of energy.
I told you in the first lecture
it uses 20 times as much energy
as a human when it walks.
People have used
these type of methods
to make a robot that uses the
same kind of energy economy
as a human.
And it's just walking with
its foot flat on the ground.
It doesn't work on
rough terrain It's
not walking as fast as we are.
All the energetics
of heel strike,
you have to do all that
with active control
because you can't sort of
reduce your collision if you're
going to land with a flat
foot, so this is a better way
to do things.
Excellent That's a quick preview
into the world of walking.
And really the key
message here is
it only takes one or two
more tools to turn it back
into the acrobat problem.
OK.
Midterm on Thursday.
If you have questions
about that, ask John.
Ask me.
If I do disappear, I apologize.
But it's for a good reason.
And we'll have a
good spring break.
And I'll see you soon.